I think that's so cute of Kim that she
was plotting and planning to have me
hook up with someone here in Milan I
really do thank you cakes
so he goes we're sitting at the show and
they sat me next to him and he's like do
you like Dolce Gabbana and I was like I
do
and I said do you like Dolce and he's
like yeah it's always been a dream of
mine since I was a kid to model for that
music and now I'm the face of Dolce and
I go oh you must really like them then
like I don't know who anyone is he's the
face of Dolce with the speedo on and no
clothes that's him coming out of a water
Fallen Capri I don't know anyone it
could be Tom Hanks and I'm like hey do
you like movies like I have no idea who
anyone is